I DON’T THINK HE KNOWS WHAT I DO
FOR A LIVING.
GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP.
MINI MIKE BLOOMBERG’S CAMPAIGN,
WE CAN OFFICIALLY REPORT IS ON
LIFE SUPPORT WITH A RESPIRATOR
AND FEEDING TUBE.
HE WAS LITERALLY RIPPED TO
SHREDS IN LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE.
I CAN’T REALLY OVERSTATE HOW
POORLY HE PERFORMED.
SINGLE WORST DEBATE PERFORMANCE
I HAVE EVER WITNESSED IN MY
LIFETIME.
FRANKLY, HE EMBARRASSED HIMSELF
AND ANYONE THAT SUPPORTS HIM.
MOSTLY HIMSELF.
WELL, HE’S HIS ONLY REAL BIG
DONOR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. BLOOMBERG HAD POLICIES IN
NEW YORK CITY OF STOP AND FRISK,
WHICH WENT OFF AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS AT AN OUTRAGEOUS WAY
THAT IS NOT A WAY TO GROW VOTER
TURNOUT.
>> I’D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WHO
WE’RE RUNNING AGAINST, A
BILLIONAIRE THAT CALLS WOMEN FAD
BROADS AND HORSE-FACED LESBIAN.
NO, NOT DONALD TRUMP.
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
>> I DON’T THINK YOU LOOK AT
DONALD TRUMP AND SAY WE NEED
SOMEBODY RICHNER THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> THE MAYOR SAYS HE HAS A GRADE
RECORD.
HE’S DONE THESE WONDERFUL
THINGS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, HE’S
NOT MANAGED HIS CITY VERY WELL
WHEN HE WAS THERE.
HE DIDN’T GET A LOT DONE.
HE HAD STOP AND FRISK, THROWING
CLOSE TO FIVE MILLION YOUNG
BLACK MEN AGAINST THE WALL.
>> WE HAD VERY FEW NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
>> HOW MANY --
>> LET ME FINISH.
NONE OF THEM ACCUSED ME OF DOING
ANYTHING OTHER THAN MAYBE THEY
DIDN’T LIKE A JOKE I TOLD.
>> Sean: THAT’S LIKE A DANA
WHITE MMA BEAT-DOWN.
YOU CAN BUY A LOT OF THINGS WITH
$500 MILLION.
YOU CAN.
BUT YOU CAN’T BUY A PERSONALITY,
CHARISMA AND YOU CAN’T EVEN BUY
GOOD DEBATE PREPARATION.
IN TWO SHORT HOURS, THIS
NEVER-ENDING SLICK $500 MILLION
MARKETING CAMPAIGN COLLAPSED
BEFORE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY’S
EYES.
THE COVER OF THE "NEW YORK POST"
CALLED IT A BRUTAL BEAT-DOWN.
EVEN THE FAR LEFT TABLOID, THE
NEW YORK DAILY NEWS COMPARED IT
TO A MASSIVE EXPLOSION.
POLITCO WRITING THAT IT WAS A
MONUMENTAL FAILURE IN TERMS OF
PREPARATION.
THE LIBERAL DAILY BEAST, THEIR
HEADLINE "BLOOMBERG HUNDREDS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO GET HIS
ASS BEAT."
CSNBC SAID BLOOMBERG TOOK A
BEATING.
FORMER OBAMA OFFICIAL VAN JONES
COMPAREDED BLOOMBERG TO THE
SINKING OF A TITANIC.
YOU KNOW, WHEN IT HIT THE
ICEBERG.
AND MR. THROW-UP CHRIS MATTHEWS
COMPARED HIM TO A PRIZE FIGHTER
THAT COULDN’T STOP BLEEDING AND
DIDN’T HAVE A CUTMAN IN HIS
CORNER.
EVEN TO CNN, IT’S UNANIMOUS, A
HORRIBLE NIGHT FOR BLOOMBERG.
YOU GET THE PICTURE?
SO THE DEMOCRATS PLAN B IS AN
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
IT IMPLODED LAST NIGHT.
WITH BIDEN AND BLOOMBERG’S EPIC
IMPLOSION, THERE’S NO PLAN C.
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE PROVED ONE
THING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS IN A
STATE OF COMPLETE AND UTTER
CHAOS AND A MELTDOWN AND ONLY
GOING TO GET WORSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE’RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
VOTES IN THE SENATE IN
WASHINGTON?
LET’S TALK ABOUT IT.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT -- [TALKING
OVER EACH OTHER].
>> HELLO, HELLO.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WARREN AND MAYOR
BLOOMBERG, THIS QUESTION IS FOR
YOU.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT -- MAYBE
THIS IS APPROPRIATE HERE.
>> CAN I DEFEND SENATOR
KLOBUCHAR FOR A MINUTE?
THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
>> Sean: LET’S SEE.
A DEVOUT SOCIALIST LEADING THE
WAY A WALL STREET BILLIONAIRE
THAT THINKS ANYBODY CAN BE A
FARMER, A HARVARD PROFESSOR, A
COUPLE OTHER SOCIOPATHS THAT ARE
HELL BENT ON FAME AND GLORY.
IT’S LIKE A SICK, TWISTED JOKE.
THE WEAKEST PRESIDENTIAL FIELD
FRANKLY IN THE HISTORY OF
AMERICAN POLITICS.
AND LAST NIGHT IT WAS
ESSENTIALLY A CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD, ALL SHOWING THEIR TRUE
COLORS.
I COULDN’T WRITE IT ANY BETTER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MOST AMERICANS DON’T SEE
WHERE THEY FIT IF THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN A SOCIALIST THAT
THINKS THAT CAPITALISM IS THE
ROOT OF ALL I’LL HAVE AND A GUY
THAT THINKS MONEY IS THE ROOT OF
ALL POWER.
>> MAYBE IT’S TIME FOR THE
WORKING CLASS OF THIS COUNTRY TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF POWER IN
WASHINGTON RATHER THAN YOUR
BILLIONAIRE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTORS.
>> IT’S NOT A PLAN, IT’S A POWER
POINT.
AMY’S PLAN IS EVEN LESS.
IT’S LIKE A POST-IT NOTE.
INSERT PLAN HERE
>> THE ONLY COMPANY WE CAN’T GO
AFTER, GUN MANUFACTURERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN IN THE ARENA
DOING THAT WORK.
YOU MEMORIZED TALKING POINTS AND
A BUNCH OF THINGS.
>> Sean: OUCH!
YOU CAN SEE IT, A BLOODBATH.
BUT THROUGH THE SHOUTING AND
IDENTITY POLITICS, WE DID LEARN
THAT THESE INSANE PEOPLE WANT TO
BE YOUR NEXT PRESIDENT OR
ACTUALLY PRETTY DUMB AND THEIR
POLICIES ARE MORE CHILLING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NBC DID A POLL YESTERDAY.
SAYS JOE BIDEN IS BEST EQUIPPED
TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S WHAT YOUR POLL SAID.
>> YOU’RE LITERALLY IN PART OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT IS OVERSEEING
THESE THINGS.
AND WE’RE NOT ABLE TO SPEAK TO
LITERALLY THE FIRST THING ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF THE CRISIS OF
OURSELVES.
>> ARE YOU TRYING TO SAY I’M
DUMB OR ARE YOU MOCKING ME HERE,
PETE?
>> WHY DO YOU COMPLAIN?
YOU WROTE THE CODE.
>> YOU DID.
YOU AND YOUR CAMPAIGN --
>> YOU AND YOUR 99 SENATORS.
>> NOT ME.
>> WHAT A WONDERFUL COUNTRY WE
HAVE.
THE BEST KNOWN SOCIALIST IS A
MILLIONAIRE WITH THREE HOUSES.
WHAT DID I MISS HERE?
>> YOU MISSED I WORK IN
WASHINGTON.
HOUSE 1.
LIVE IN BURLINGTON.
HOUSE 2.
AND LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHERS,
HAVE A SUMMER CAMP.
FORGIVE ME FOR THAT.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> I WISH EVERYONE WAS AS
PERFECT AS YOU, PETE.
>> Sean: YES, BENNY SANDERS, THE
SOVIET-STYLE MILLIONAIRE THAT
WANTS TO ELIMINATE CAPITALISM.
WHAT I’M ABOUT TO TELL YOU
SHOULD SHOCK YOU.
BERNIE SANDERS IS THE FRONT
RUNNER.
NOW THIS IS WHAT I’VE BEEN
SAYING.
THE NEW RADICAL EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY OF
AMERICA, THAT’S THE SAME GUY
THAT WANTS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONFISCATE YOUR
PRIVATE PROPERTY, YOUR WEALTH,
NATIONALIZE OUR ENTIRE ENERGY
INDUSTRY, GET OFF OIL AND GAS
COMPLETELY.
THE LIFE BLOOD OF THE WORLD’S
ECONOMY.
NATIONALIZE YOUR HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY.
HOW DID OBAMACARE WORK OUT?
PUT A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
AMERICANS ARE ACTUALLY ALLOWED
TO EARN.
DRAMATICALLY RAISE TAXES ON
EVERYBODY MAKING OVER $29,000 A
YEAR.
THAT MEANS ANYBODY.
THE SAME GUY THAT PRAISED ONLY
EVERY COMMUNIST DICTATOR AROUND
THE GLOBE, THE GUY THAT ACTUALLY
HONEYMOONED IN THE FORMER SOVIET
UNION.
THE COMMUNIST SOVIET UNION.
NOW THE WHACK JOB
PSEUDO-COMMUNIST, HE COULD BE
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
TONIGHT WE CAN REPORT THAT IT
SEEMS UNLIKELY THAT BERNIE WILL
GET THE DELEGATES NEEDED TO GET
THE DOMINATION OUTRIGHT, WHICH
MEANS THIS ULTIMATE SCHIFF SHOW
WILL GET MUCH WORSE.
BUCKLE UP.
ODDS ARE HIGH, WE’RE HEADED TO A
CONTESTED CONVENTION.
TOP DEMOCRATS ARE PLOTTING A WAY
TO RIP THIS NOMINATION FROM
BERNIE’S COLD SOCIALIST HANDS
AND IN FACT, LAST NIGHT’S
DEBATE, NO CANDIDATE ON STAGE
EXCEPT FOR BERNIE AGREED THAT
THE PRIMARY WINNER SHOULD GO TO
THE CANDIDATE WITH THE MOST
VOTES OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY ALL AGREED THAT THE PROCESS
SHOULD PLAY OUT.
SO SUPER DELEGATES, IN OTHER
WORDS, DEMOCRATIC HIERARCHY HAVE
MORE SAY AT THE CONVENTION ON
THE SECOND BALLOT THAN THE
PEOPLE THAT GO OUT AND VOTE AND
CAUCUS.
SO THAT’S RIGHT.
SOME OF THE VERY SAME PEOPLE, BY
THE WAY, INCLUDES ELIZABETH
WARREN AND MAYOR PETE THAT WANT
TO ELIMINATE THE LECTORAL
NOMINATION, THEY WANT TO STEAL
IT FROM BERNIE AGAIN.
BRACE YOUR ZEST.
WE’RE MONTHS AWAY FROM POLITICAL
CHAOS LIKE WE HAVE NEVER
WITNESSED BEFORE.
THIS IS BASICALLY THE APPETIZER.
THIS IS JUST THE OPENING SALVO,
IF YOU WILL, A PREVIEW OF COMING
ATTRACTIONS.
THE ONLY QUESTION TONIGHT IS
WILL BERNIE TAKING LYING DOWN
LIKE IN 2016.
HE AND HIS SUPPORTERS LET THE
DNC SLAP THEM AROUND AGAIN OR
WILL IT TURN INTO A CIVIL WAR.
CAN’T PREDICT THE FUTURE.
WE SHOULDN’T TAKE AN ELECTION
FOR GRANTED.
STAKES ARE TOO HIGH FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
BUT LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE HAD A
CLEAR WINNER AND IT WAS NOT
ANYONE ON THAT STATEMENT.
EVEN MINI MIKE BLOOMBERG SEES
THE WRITING IS ON THE WALL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO HOW WAS YOUR NIGHT LAST
NIGHT?
LOOK, THE REAL WINNER THE DEBATE
LAST NIGHT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
BECAUSE I WORRY THAT WE MAY WELL
BE ON THE WAY TO NOMINATING
SOMEBODY THAT CANNOT WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
IF WE CHOOSE A CANDIDATE THAT
APPEALS TO A SMALL BASE LIKE
SENATOR SANDERS, IT WILL BE A
FATAL ERROR.
>> FARMER MIKE MAY BE RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ARE LIMPING INTO
NEVADA AND SOUTH CAROLINA RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER SUPER TUESDAY,
THIS IS GOING TO GET BLOODIER
AND UGLIER FAST.
WITH REPUBLICANS, ALL UNITED